it's written about route 66 which was
that used to be the main highway between
Chicago Illinois
Angeles California very famous highway
because anybody wanted to go
cross-country always took route 66
because it was the shortest way to go
and the question is how do you find the
shortest path not just any old path or a
good path how do you find the very
shortest path and that will be the
subject that we're going to discuss
today but route 66 of oh I meant it's
passing but it's been largely replaced
by the interstate highway system that
was created by President Eisenhower
guess why let's see maybe the ROTC
people know and know why
Eisenhower created the interstate
highway system well in public affairs of
course there's always a distinction to
be made between the explanation and the
reason the explanation was well who
nuclear weapons across the country let's
put it in slightly but more benign terms
Eisenhower had observed that the German
army was able to move its troops rapidly
even though we bombed their railroads
into oblivion because of their Autobahn
so Eisenhower conceived that if there
ever an invasion in the United States we
too would want to be able to move our
forces around on a highway system and
consequence of that we have a pretty
good highway system a pretty awful
railroad system interesting I'm a
beneficiary of that and funny in a funny
way because I'm from East Peoria
Illinois and I was surrounded by the
factories of caterpillar Tractor Company
which made all the tractors that built
all those roads so my high school cents
spent money like water from that huge
tax base of all those factories anyway
today we want to find the very best path
instead of just a good path and like the
last time we'll deal with both a both an
example that we can set our program to
work on
by the way can you find the shortest
path between s and G would you like to
bet your life on the shortest path
between s and G probably not with your
eye you can find a good path but you
can't find the best possible path it's
probably today what we're doing is
probably not modeling any obvious
property of what we have inside our
heads but being able to find the best
path as part of the skill set that
anybody who's had of course artificial
intelligence would be expected to have
so we're going to look at it even though
it's not like many of the things we do a
model of something that's probably going
on in your head so we're going to use
both this example from Cambridge and our
blackboard example let's see we have to
have our we have to caution ourselves
right tongue is is search about maps no
it's about what starts with a C and it
next letter is H and it ends up being
choice so so we're talking about choice
not about maps even though our examples
are drawn from maps because they're
convenient they're visual and it helps
understand the concepts behind the
algorithms I'm talking about so let's
start off by looking at our classroom
example and I did something today that I
neglected to do last time
and that's talked to you about what I
meant by heuristic distance it's those
pink lines that I just drew on the map
we're talking about the distance as if
the crow would fly between two places
even though there's no road that goes
between those two places so in general
and we discussed last time in general
it's best to get yourself into a place
that's close as the crow flies to your
goal and of course that's a heuristic
and it can get you in trouble because
it's not always true it would appear
that being at node E is a good place to
be because it's not very far from G but
in that particular case designed to
illustrate the point being close is
actually not a good thing because it's a
it's a dead end but in general it's a
good thing to be close and when we
talked last time about
climbing and beam search being close was
the objective of those kinds of searches
and at one point in a beam search
illustration we had C be a and D we had
past terminating in all four of those
nodes as candidates for the next round
of search and we decided on the basis of
these airline distances to keep D and B
and reject a and C because they're
further away as the crow flies now
repeat this even though many of you have
had this fixed already in your tutorials
because we're going to need this concept
of heuristic distance today and I wanted
to be sure that that point has been
clarified so now with a smaller map I
imagine you can do by eye a
determination of what the shortest path
is what is it Juana you help me out with
that si DG and if you add up those
distances the distance is 11 along that
path that goes from s first to a and
then to D and then from D to G so one
our search that that is the best path
and we're going to treat Juana as an
Oracle because we're going to follow and
our initial attempt to understand these
algorithms a very important principle of
problem solving and that is that if you
want to solve a problem the easiest way
is usually to ask somebody who knows the
answer or Google which also probably
knows the answer so we've in this
particular case we believe that Juana
knows the answer and she said that the
shortest path is si DG and its path
length is 11 but we don't trust her
because we're applying to the same
Medical School and she may be trying to
spruce
okay so we want to be very cautious
about accepting her answer until we've
checked it to make sure that she hasn't
attempted to delude us so how would we
go about doing that well one way to do
that is to check to be sure that all
other possible paths that we could
develop end up being for sure longer
than the one that wanted has told us
about
so she's told us about s a D G and it
has a total path length of 11 and now
what I'm going to do is I'm just going
to develop the rest of the of this tree
like diagram more or less than a but
what I'm going to do is I'm actually not
going to do it in a British Museum a
random way what I'm going to do is I'm
or you going to look at the choice that
corresponds the shortest path that can
be extended so the shortest path that
can be extended is this one right here
the one that just has the starting node
in it and I could have gone this other
way to be and if I go that other way to
be then the path length along that side
is five and likewise I could have gone
to if I look at the path that terminates
an a that had that has a path length of
three so now I've got two choices a and
B I've got choices that extend beyond
those two places so I'm always going to
extend the one that has the shorter the
shorter length so in this case that
would be the path that goes from s to a
so if I go from s a I don't have to go
to D I can also go to B and if I go to B
then the accumulated path length the
accumulated path length is s a B that's
seven and notice though that we're
talking now about the path like the
accumulated path length that we travel
so far last time we were talking a lot
about distances to the goal heuristic
estimates of how far we are from the
goal now we're doing
exactly the opposite we're not
considering how far we've got to go
we're only thinking about how far we've
gone so far so now repeating these steps
again I've got seven and five so I'll go
over and consider the choices that go
through from through the B node them on
the path s B and that gives me s B a and
s B C and what are those path lengths
well let's see
SP a would be 9 and SB C would be 9 and
now the shortest path is this one over
here so I extend that I go for sa b
this.a b only place I can go is C that
adds another 4 so that's 11 and what do
I know about that path I don't have to
take that any further right because the
path length path distance I've gone on
that path already is equal to the path
length that Juana has told me gets me to
the goal so it would be full foolhardy
to carry on because presuming that these
links are all non-negative I can't get
any I can't do any better and I can't
even do as well unless I've got a link
that has zero life so now that I have
that idea I can quickly finish up by
saying well let me consider these two
paths sb a can only go to D and if I go
to D that adds 3 I plus 3 is 12 nothing
else can happen there because that's 12
and I've got a path of the goal that's
11 C and can only go to e it's a
dead-end but I don't have to think about
that because I know that the accumulated
distance along this path is 6 plus 9 is
15 so all of these need not be extended
any further because their length the
accumulated so far is equal to or less
than the length of the goal so I've
checked the Oracle and all those who are
applying to the same Medical School Lana
has told me the truth
so now unfortunately one is not always
around and I don't always have an Oracle
so I'm going to add I'm going to have to
have some way of finding the shortest
path without that Oracle that I can they
can check against and just let's see
what can I do maybe I can maybe I can do
the same thing I just did always extend
the shortest path so far and hope that I
run into the goal some at some point and
then I have to ask myself the question
how much extra work did I need to do
when I don't have the Oracle well let's
just try it and see what happens I don't
have that path start with so I just have
s its distance is zero I can go either A
or B if I go to a I've got a distance of
three here I've got a distance of five
I'll extend the path that goes si that
can either go to B or D going to be or D
gives me seven that way si D gives me
six so looking across all of these and
extending the shortest path so far takes
me back over to s B so I extend those s
B takes me to a or C and those in turn
have a total accumulated path lengths of
nine and nine now the shortest one is si
D you see the pattern now let's see I
haven't found the goal yet so I can ask
myself the question is any of the work
that I've done so far wasted no because
all of the paths that I've got so far
are shorter than the path of the goal
because the goal hasn't shown up so when
I do my Oracle checking after I found
the goal none of that work is going to
be wasted so in the end I don't actually
need the Oracle I can just develop this
graph by extending the shortest path so
far
until I hit the goal and then do a
perhaps a little remaining checking to
make sure that all the other paths
extend with a length that's greater than
the path of the goal so if those words
are confusing let's carry on with the
algorithm I think they'll be clearer so
let's see we've got the seven six and
two nines we going to extend the one
that's six that gets us to the goal and
we've got it and we've got a path length
of eleven but note that we can't quit
because we have to be sure that all
other paths are longer than eleven so
now we have to carry on with the same
algorithm that we started with the
Oracle checking algorithm and when we do
that we look for the shortest path so
far that has not been extended that's B
s a B goes to C that's 11 so we're done
there a goes to D that adds 3 that's 12
C goes to e that adds 6 that's 15 and
sure enough we're done ok Elliot
this question is does it know that there
is no zero distance link that's coming
up that's an implementation detail this
guarantees you find a path that's as
short as any that you possibly find but
there might be others if there are zero
length lengths right as long as there
are non-negative links we're safe we've
got a shortest path so that was easy and
now we can repeat the exercise with our
more complicated map of Cambridge
first of all let's do depth first just
to recall what that looks like that is
certainly not a short path so let's try
this idea which by the way bears the
label branch-and-bound
let's try branching bound on the same
map and there it goes each of those
little flickers is trying another path
so you can see it it's working its guts
out to find that shortest path
it's almost there but it's it's almost a
pathological case where it's almost
doing British Museum there has finally
found the shortest path now there's some
things we can ask about that but first
of all before I ask anything about it
I'd like to get the flow chart up on the
board because we're going to decorate
that flow chart out but as we go so the
first thing we do is initialize Q then
we're going to test first path on the Q
then we might be happy because we might
be done we we might have a shortest path
ago actually that's not quite true is it
we have to be we can't really quit until
that short every other path is it well
now that's interesting
do we do if we've taken the first if the
first element on the Q gets us all the
way to the goal and we've sorted our
queue by path length are we through as
soon as that first element on the queue
gets us to the goal yeah because every
other path must have been sorted passed
you know sort of beyond it and and
therefore can't be can't can't offer us
a shorter path of a goal so the first
path is a path ago we're done last it
usually isn't so we'll extend first path
we're going to put all those extensions
back on the queue and then we're going
to sort them so that's pretty much the
same as we did last time we're always
going to put the elements back on the
queue I'm going to look at the first
element on the queue and see if it's a
winner if it is we're done if it's not
we're going to extend it and then go
back in here and try again well sort of
how but we noted that this did an awful
lot of work because we look at those
statistics up there it put 1354 paths
onto the queue that's the in queueing
part and then it extended 835 paths that
had come to the front of the queue now
I'd like to give you an aside because
it's easy to get confused about in
queueing and extending in all of the
searches we did last time it would have
been perfectly reasonable to keep a list
of all of the paths that we had put onto
the queue an in queueing list and never
put a path on the I never never add a
path to our queue if it terminates in a
node that some other path terminates in
that has already gone to the gone onto
the queue what I said last time is let
us keep track of the things that have
been extended and not extend them again
so you can either keep track of the
nodes that have been extended and not
extend them again or look at the nodes
that have pads with those that terminate
in blah blah blah and then put on the
queue being cubed once and not put
things back on the queue again and I
think last time I may have put a column
in there that said in queued it should
have been extended even though in queued
work last time only extended works this
time because we want to be sure that
anything we extend is a short path
so the the in cute idea doesn't work at
all for these optimal paths so now I
want to come back over here off the
sidebar and say that we're keeping track
of all the nose all of the paths that
end in nodes
unless they have already been extended
beyond that particular place so we need
to decorate our algorithm here and say
test first half and extend the first
path if not already extended because you
can see that in the example I had so far
we did that same silliness that we
talked about last time we extended paths
that went through a more than once like
so would it ever make sense to extend
this path now because we've already
extended a path that got there with less
distance whatever makes sense to extend
this path now because we've already
extended another path that gets to be by
a shorter distance so if we keep an
extended list we can add that to branch
and bound to our advantage so let's see
how the that would actually work on the
classroom example and then we'll do
Cambridge so this is branch and bound
plus an extended list and I do mean
extended not an acute list and cute
lists won't work here so let's see I
start off the same way as I did before s
goes to either A or B that's a length of
three that's a length of five so I
extend a that goes to either B or D
but B is as if it wasn't there at all oh
sorry
hang on he goes there and those path
lengths are seven and six and now I look
around on the board and I say what is
the shortest path so far and it's B so I
extend that to get to a and C with path
lengths of nine and nine and what's the
shortest one next its D and that goes to
G and the path length is 11 and what's
the shortest one on the board the one
that has to be extended next that's this
one that gets to be but I've already
extended a path that gets to be so I
don't actually do that extension so I've
saved some work but I've got to go over
here and do these two now but wait I've
already extended B are very extended a
so I don't have to do that one either
the only one I have to do is the one
that goes to C and that goes them to e
with the path length of 15 and I'm done
so if you compare this one with the
previous one you can see that there
might be vast areas of this tree that
are pruned away and don't have to be
examined at all
so now just for the sake of illustrating
that I would like to keep track of just
one of those statistics the number of
extensions so for this particular
example case 1 the number of extensions
was 835 why don't you see if you can
kind of guess to yourself what it would
be if I use of this concept of an
extended list see I'm not going to
extend anything I've already extended
because it's guaranteed to have a longer
path length than something that already
got to that same place so it makes no
sense to do it so let me change the type
to a branch and bound with an extended
list I'm going to turn the speed down a
little bit so we can watch it might take
the rest of the hour who knows
still doing a lot of work still
examining a lot of paths
but look at that instead of 835
extensions in only 238 so that's a
pretty substantial savings and you would
never not want to do that so note that
that's a layering on top of branching
down
that's not a different algorithm it's an
adjustment and improvement to the
algorithm then makes it more efficient
so this whole thing is based in on on
what I call the dead horse principle as
soon as we figure out that a path that
goes to a particular place can't
possibly be the winning path we get rid
of it and don't bother extending it as a
dead horse principle but if we look at
this example what's the shortest
possible length of a path that's already
gone from s to B what do you think Tanya
well first of all it can't be less than
5 because we've already gone that
distance so when I say what's the
shortest length of any path that there
could possibly be there those are the s
to D we know it's at least 5 but can we
say something more about it especially
when we look at these airline distances
and note that this is airline distance
is 6 and that's a little more than 7 and
that's a little more than 7 so what do
you think
so it's gone from s to B and the
question is what's the shortest path
that could possibly be that has started
out going from s to D
a little more because we can't have a
path that's shorter than the airline
distance if there were a straight line
road from E to G its length would be six
but there isn't so that gives us a kind
of lower bound on the distance that we
have along that path so we're using the
accumulated distance plus the airline
distance to give us a lower bound on
that on the path that we've started up
we started off on from it that goes from
s to B once again let's solidify this a
little bit by simulating the search
seeing what how it turns out now just as
I did last time I'm going to forget that
I've got an extended list so we don't I
don't want to carry both those things
around with me at the same time so we'll
forget that we're going to have that
we've got an extended list we'll bring
out those all those back together the
later so we're going to forget what we
just did there and instead we're just
going to use this concept of an airline
distance and see what happens
so as before we start with the starting
node we have two choices as always we
can go to a or b and the accumulated
distance if we go to a is three and the
accumulated distance if we go to B is
five but now we're going to add in the
airline distances so the airline
distance from A to G is a little more
than seven which is ten plus the airline
distance from B to G is exactly six so
that gives us 11 and following the
procedure we've already been using
already so far we're going to extend the
path that seems to have the shortest
potential now it's the shortest
potential distance from s to G so that
must be this one here so from a we can
go to B or D the accumulated distance si
B is seven the airline distance is six
so that's equal to 11 by standard
arithmetic 13 the the distance si D that
is 6 plus a little more than 7 that
poops
that's what's the accumulated distance
is si D is 3 plus 3 plus 3 is 6 right
what
would be five right so the airline
distance in this case is the same as the
actual distance so the accumulated
distance is six the actual distance is
five so that's equal to eleven all right
so now I've got two 11s on the board and
simulating what we'd asked you to do in
a quiz we don't know which of those is
going to be better they've got a tie
score so what we're going to do is we're
going to choose the one that's lexically
least so B is comes before D so we'll
expand B and that can go to either a or
C and we have to calculate the best
possible distance that goes along those
paths the accumulated distance s be a
sea-90 that's 16 plus this has an
accumulated distance of 9 also plus 7
plus also 16 plus oh well now let's see
things are shaping up pretty well
because this one has the lowest score so
far we extend that to G and now the
accumulated distance is 11 the airline
distance is 0 so that's 11 and that's
smaller than everybody else so we've got
it
so now compare this one with our
branch-and-bound graph and you see once
again that we've done considerably less
work and that in many practical cases
means that instead of taking more than
the remaining lifetime in the universe
to complete the calculation it can
happen in a few seconds but let's see
how it works on the example so I'm not
going to use the extended list I'm just
going to use this idea of using the
lower bound on the distance remaining
the airline distance and see what
happens
this time the number of extensions is 70
so didn't do quite as well as working
alone as the extended listed working
alone so we immediately conclude that
the extended list is more useful than
using one of these lower bound new risks
by the way this is called an admissible
heuristic so if an estimate of the
remaining distance is a lower bound on
the actual distance is less than the law
sorry if the if the heuristic estimate
is less guaranteed to be less than the
actual distance that's called an
admissible heuristic admissible because
you can use it for this kind of purpose
so it looks like the extended list is a
more useful idea an admissible idea
right what do you think about that
beretta am I am I am I am i hacking am i
joking I'm why am i judging prematurely
what do you think it might depend on
well just read us said something
unintelligible that I can't think how to
repeat what he meant to say though was
that in these cases it almost always
depends on the problem itself if you
change the problem you may get a
different result
so why don't we change the problem and
see if we get a different result so
instead of starting on the extreme left
let's start in the middle and see what
happens so I'll read just my starting
position to be right there
oops that's the wrong and desperate and
we might as well start by getting our
baseline the branch-and-bound without
anything and for that one maybe we'll
speed it up a little bit so that gives
us 57 extensions it's an easier problem
so let's try it with the admissible
heuristic oh that went too fast
Wow still pretty fast six extensions
what do you think this numbers going to
be closer to six are closer to 57 better
than six worse than six well let's think
what we're going to do is we're going to
just not repeat any any any movements
through the same note again but it's not
going to do something very important for
us it's not going to keep us out of the
left side right because there's it has
no idea of the remaining distance but
airline distance to the goal so let's
see if that's true
well sure is look at that it is
foolishly spending a lot of its time
doing something we would never do namely
looking over there on the left side so
this time the number of extensions is 35
so in case to the admissible heuristic
does very much better in case one the
extension thing does much better but
wait a minute
would we ever not want to use both at
the same time now whenever not we
wouldn't want it we wouldn't use want to
use just one of these right they both
seem to have the possibility of doing a
lot of good so maybe if we put them in
harness together we'll get something
that's even better and when we do that
see here the extended list is a layer on
top of branch-and-bound the admissible
heuristic is another layer on top of
branch-and-bound
if we put those together we get
something called a star so a star is
just branch-and-bound plus an extended
list plus an admissible heuristic so
let's go back to our original problem
and try a star on that
we're running this at a previous low
speed because we're expecting it to be a
lot more efficient than the original
branching down and sure enough it is
number of extensions is 27 so look at
that a lot better than either of those
working independently now we can stick
the thing in the center and see what
happens then
boom six so in this particular case the
extended list and actually helped us
because our admissible heuristic was
channeling us so tightly toward the goal
didn't matter so it all depends on the
honest on the nature of the space that
you're trying to explore by the way you
now have the whole works right so what
you want to do is you want to extend the
first path and sort but not just by
accumulated distance sort by accumulated
distance plus admissible heuristic the
where the theoreticians you must be
complaining sorts expensive do we need
to actually do the short do we actually
need to sort now we don't actually need
to sort what do we need to do we just
need to keep track of what's the minute
so we don't need to actually do that
sort that's an unnecessary computation
so instead we can test got the first
path with the shortest path now you have
it might have a hold a start and now you
can go home but I don't think you should
because I'm about to show you a that
this idea of admissibility actually
leads to certain screw cases that we're
very fond of asking about on exams
alright so it turns out that the
admissible heuristic in certain
circumstances can get you into trouble
it doesn't look like it could because
logically nothing I've said seems
strange or questionable but that's
because I've been working with a map and
it turns out that if you work with a map
then the miscibility is a perfectly
sound way of doing an optimal search but
us just search just about maps no sir
not just about math so we may have non
non Euclidean arrangements that will
cause us trouble so I'd like to
illustrate that with a following example
it's not going to be a large map or
large graph s and go up here to a or
down here to B then they merge at C and
then they go out here to the golgi and
the actual distances are 1 1 1 and 10
and over here we'll make that a hundred
so it's a kind of oddly constructed math
but it's there because we need a
pathological case to illustrate the idea
now that's the actual distances and if
we did branch-and-bound with an extended
list everything would work just fine but
we're not we're going to use it
admissible heuristic and we're going to
say that this guy has an estimated
distance to the goal of 100 this guy is
zero and this guy is zero zero is always
an underestimate of the actual distance
to the goal right so I'm always free to
use zero is that 100 okay
yeah because the the actual distance is
101 so it's less than the actual
distance so it's oh so it's okay as an
admissible heuristic so these numbers
that I put up here are together
constitute an admissible heuristic set
of estimates to the goal so now let's
just simulate a star and see what
happens so first of all you start with s
and that can either go to a or be the
actual distance is 1 plus the an
estimate on the remaining distance that
gives us 100 plus 100 that's equal to
101 if we go to B instead the actual
distance is 1 plus the heuristics
distance is 0 so that's equal to 1 okay
good so now we know that we always
extend the shortest path so far
did I goof this are you asking a
question yeah they fully fits the actual
when I say actually it's the pet to
stick actual distance to you properly so
so it's like if I go from s to a the
actual distance I travel is one so
that's all so now I'm taking the sum of
the actual distance plus the estimated
distance to go see this is this is not a
matter she was asking if this if the the
map has to be geometrically accurate see
this could be a model of something
that's not a map and so I'm free to put
any numbers on those links that I want
including the estimates as long as
they're under estimates of the distance
along the links so this tells me that my
estimated distance here so far is 1 so
I'll surely go down here to see and if I
go to see then my accumulated distance
is 11 and my estimate of the remaining
distance is 0 so that's a total of 11 so
now I'm following my heuristic again and
saying what's the shortest what's the
shortest path on the basis of the
accumulated distance plus the estimated
distance here the accumulated distance
plus the estimated distance is 101 here
it's only 11 so plainly I extend this
guy and that gets me to the goal and the
total distance total accumulated
distance is now 111 plus 0 equals 111
and that's not the shortest path the
weight I still have to do my checking
right I have to extend a and when I
extend a I get to be and now when I get
to be that way my accumulated distance
is two plus my oh sorry si si
my accumulated distance is two my
estimated distance is zero so that's
equal to two so I'm okay because I'm
still going to extend this guy right
wrong I've already extended that guy so
I'm I'm host like I won't find the
shortest path because that I'm going to
stop there and I'm going to stop there
because this is a admissible heuristic
and that's not good enough unless it's a
map it's not good enough in this
particular case because this is not GMAT
this connect cannot be done as a map on
a plane so that's that's a situation
where what I've talked to you about so
far works with branch-and-bound works
with branch-and-bound plus an extended
list but doesn't work when we added an
admissible heuristic so if we're going
to do this in general we need something
stronger than a miscibility which works
only on maps and so the flourish then
I'll tell you about here in the last few
seconds of today's lecture
is to add a refinement
as follows so far we've got a
miscibility and if we want to write this
down in a kind of mathematical notation
we can say that it's admissible at the
estimated distance between any node X
and the goal is less than or equal to
the actual distance between X and the
goal that's definition of the
miscibility as long as the risk is
admissible and a star works if it's a
map but for that kind of situation where
it's not a map we need a stronger
condition which is called consistency
and what that says is that the distance
between X and the goal minus the
distance between some other node and the
goal Y take the absolute value of that
that has to be less than or equal to the
actual distance between x and y so does
this mystic satisfy the consistency
condition well let's see here the guess
is a is 100 here at 0 so that so the
absolute difference is 100 but the
actual distance is only 2 so it
satisfies the miscibility but it doesn't
satisfy consistency and it doesn't work
so you can almost be guaranteed it will
give you a situation where if you use a
admissible heuristic you'll lose and you
and and and if you use a consistent
heuristic you'll still win ok so how can
we bring this back into the fold well we
can't use that you ristic it's no good
but at this to guesstimate of the goal
were to there would be ok because then
it would still be it would still be
admissible but it would also be
consistent alright so the bottom line is
that you now know something you didn't
know when you started out
two lectures ago you now know how
MapQuest and all of its descendants work
now you can find an optimal path as well
as a heuristic a good path you see that
if you don't do anything other than
branch-and-bound it can be extremely
expensive and you can even invent
pathological cases where it's
exponential and the distance to the to
the goal so because it can be so
computationally horrible you want to use
every advantage you can which generally
involves using an extended list as well
as no laptops plays it still holds no
smoking no drinking and no laptops so
you can use it so you use all the
muscles you can and those muscles
include using an extended list and an
admissible or consistent heuristic
depending on the circumstances and so I
think we'll conclude there since our
time is up and elet you can ask a
question after class why did you come up
and ask her now
you